some of the key challenges for me going
into 2018 dira d'Italia will be just the
fact that it's a whole different
structure coming into the race we have
Kris going for the bureau for the first
time in a number of years JIRA can be
very mixed in in whether it will be very
very hot
or it can be very very cold it's that
time of year in May when the weather is
a bit unpredictable I think for Kris the
biggest challenge will potentially be
the cold weather not not the heat we
know once they start going up north it
potentially we could have quite a lot of
snow in the mountains you're just
burning more trying to keep your body
warm you've literally got it beep
sterling even more so times of sport
jails more bars you need to be drinking
just as much as well it's a lot of
climbing in the Giro for 2019 we know
it's a big challenge so obviously you
know weight is gonna be a big factor for
the riders we're putting a lot of work
around that and obviously the big part
is nutrition it's certainly not easy on
a Grand Tour just to be up there every
single day it's three weeks which is
just completely relentless you get your
recovery right get your sleep right get
your nutrition right it certainly makes
it a lot easier it's a tough balance but
I'm confident with the support that we
have from science and sport we'll we'll
get that right